37:13 since 1930
emergency evacuation you shouldn't be
like that it's rated for yes okay just
before we we do start I just like to
welcome Simon Simon wouldn't belong to
his first executive meeting thank you he
mentioned George George whoever's got
twenty personal issues to deal with has
stood down and silence we throw these
little thank you so much that such as
the life of the council but anyway
welcome so making apologies for absence
we have counsel award I'm sorry to say
has got a detached retina those he had
operation just to be had go back to the
hospital dying and but
Sheridan I've had a call proceed we need
to say that he was sparing has got
exactly the same problem we've got in
touch
non-members attending that doesn't have
any at all maybe meetings of the meeting
held on the 10th of July 2000 my thing
is everybody happy those are some hos
yeah declarations of interest
okay matters referred from the
executives and enforcement permittees
there are which moves to straight onto
the first item on the agenda which in
item six quarter 1 2019 financial
finance just start very briefly in that
pass over to them and then come back
again again but this is offer the first
quarter
quite quite active but you can already
see the evidence of effective management
of the council's finances as there is a
a small very small there is a variance
positive variance projected to the end
of the year but I'm faster now me
straight straight away to cover some of
the detail you don't have to
for the council I forget about the end
of the financial year it also sets out
the capsules key performance indicators
independence
why so the latest revenue budget for the
council is just over 10 million pounds
which is an increase of just under
100,000 pounds compared to the original
budget consensus started the year the
reasons for that is not in paragraph
three point two that said to me they are
drawdowns reserves for specific items
that we approved at various member
meetings and since the start of the year
so for example and the agreed
expenditure on the asset program and it
supports an increase in the budget and
some budgets have had grants which have
been bullied a lot of the year as well
so as council Smith said it's positive
and position overall in that we
objecting and understand at 175 176
thousand pounds what is a year just to
make contacts Allah
text artist contrite stood aside to set
to play I wore net revenue budget so
while it is positive it yeah it's not
huge in terms of the overall model of
the council spends members will be aware
that we sent a vacancy factor economy
budgets at the start of the year so that
basically means that we know at any
point to the tribe we won't have a
completely closed off establishment and
we projected that we were able to make
the saving on our 200,000 pounds over
the course of the financial year at this
point of the year we're suggesting that
we will overachieve on that salary
saving and we're actually make a saving
around 300,000 counts so roughly a
hundred thousand accounts or of the own
world spend it's being driven through an
additional vacancies in the staffing
establishments in addition there's a
couple of other key areas where the
council is projecting a better than
expected position one of those
additional income from car parks in
original 15,000 pounds and the other one
main one is the good news story in terms
of the ongoing focus of prevention work
which is they must realize yet for
saving
hibiscus project so they are the main
drivers of projected under spend at
least question of the year and was
obviously more detail in the appendices
internship that's made up or but have
been much worse particular questions
because we have to try not to those now
or to take those away an audience about
in terms of the capital program possess
a capital program including the number
of items which are well for complete
this years of about 3.2 million
at the moment we're forecasting we were
will only spent about 2.3 million but
the main driver in the the reduction in
sped that we're anticipating for this
year is actually the profiling of me
playgrounds program that we agreed when
we agreed that at the start of the year
that was we put all the budget for that
plane to as playgrounds works in this
one year of another previous and
actually meeting we've agreed to
actually profile the spending on those
playground works over the course of a
year so we will still spend with that
money but it will just be focused
slightly on the period that we
that's the main roads on the capital
program that we're projecting that's
probably all I was going to draw your
attention to at this stage but as a fan
I'm going to come back then just a
additional bit of note about the play at
playground
you could you could read what we said
about
reprofiling the playground investment
has just expressed just as what patrons
know nothing about profiling the
playground investment that is done for a
specific purpose obviously there's the
the ability to plan to get contractors
on board as well but also its to enable
us to access grant money on a regular
basis because so far that has been very
successful in bringing even more income
to the project and they even more
playground and referral refurbishments
the the money that's projected as a
surplus is is not a vast amount in terms
of what we turn over as a council but it
is an amount of money that can make a
difference when we set the budget we set
a balanced budget we didn't set the
budget hoping that we wouldn't make some
savings because we got some other other
projects
it's our effective administration of the
council that is allowing this surplus to
build we've made proper plans for our
investments and capital investment since
I wanted it as Gnomeo said with in
excess of 2 million pounds to be spent
this year with even more allocated so
we're in a positive position so what I
think we we should do and I would like
to start to develop proposals with
executive members health is how we can
help our residents our own hands are the
provision of what we do to residents by
looking at some modest projects that
don't have a particular ongoing revenue
implication to reallocate some of that
money so that within this current
financial year
we spend some more of it in areas where
we can make a difference and it's a it's
early days yet but certainly in in some
discussions with members
I think projects that tidy and enhance
the presentation of our district do seem
to be particularly popular and I'm sure
our residents would would thank us for
further enhancing the quality of life by
making Raley and Rockford and the other
smaller smaller settlements even nicer
places in which to live so I think that
their plans that we can perhaps think
about from one week of this ongoing
position at the end of court to I'd like
us to put certain that proposals forward
to see how we can develop some swapping
I just want us all to know that I've
talked to you all
the other questions
accidentally to have a decision will be
recommended on the page like one
it is
two recommendations what word one one
here to our members happy to accept them
as printed
item seven which is the future leisure
services provision
make Germantown did this report follows
River supports the exact workers to set
out a strategy for future British
service provision making the council
latest we've said before chairman that
the council's legislate are significant
council accents they do provide
important services they're very well
supported by the community they serve so
collaboration we've given really early
consideration of future options for an
basically provision to allow sufficient
time for a real robust and sarra process
to be followed
members will record I the letter and
cultural services strategy was approved
and that was a key doctor when they sent
out the process and also the objectives
for Malaysia at the next 10 years of the
letter service and that were a key
reference document in order to protect
this program forward we didn't the
report members a number of potential
leadership associates present options
have been appraised of those available
and they are set out in the report in
inform the contract model as satire in
the report would enable the council to
specified services and commercial
outcomes by are a competitive
procurement process and should provide
the optimal balance of control and
certainty through ongoing oversight as a
management of the contract - sure that's
funny
Kirra supporters have set out that
officers was approached to market to
carry out a sub market testing process
and the high level outcomes are referred
to within the report we had a real
healthy response from leading
contractors well-known contractors
within the sector with extensive
portfolios both nationally or by treaty
and nationally showing were at the
interesting amount and our facilities
which booze which is good to note this
early stage and that covers such areas
such as potential financial models
possible contract terms areas for
innovation operational considerations
and their approach to marketing
this is an early soft market testing
phase so this isn't setting down
definitive options this is testing
what's possible what's feasible given to
me how to tender this contract for what
the new xx over the long term
contractors members will be aware
finally as part of the process offices i
spoke with other local authorities have
been through a similar process they have
experiences in procuring similar
contracts and i think what we've learned
from that was given the the size of the
the contract the numbers of presidents
using the service that bring in external
support and advice was it was a real
clear recommendation to make sure we get
that specification right it will be a
long term
contract for this council with
considerable members and residents and
using the facilities in closing reports
sets out the early work that we've
completed to appraise the delivery
options tester market through a soft
market testing process and how we would
go forward develop the contract
specification to deliver those
objectives which members previously and
approves with the elation Corporate
Services strategy happens take any
question
yes I think it is worth recognizing that
we planning has started early church
with the best possible outcome for our
residents this is a significant contract
this is the first time whatever twenty
years ago brought this forward and I
think it's one of his proper that we're
giving it a good running time to make
sure the best outcome for residents one
thing we're never been a reporter just
ask all members attention to the stock
market testing as committee could only
stay in terms of what the new
to deliver and that was potentially
there for the council to invest in the
inception of the new contracts so that's
like to see I think things just
something that remembers to be aware of
that kind of starts vomiting
very much in control this process
that's ready thanks Matt for you recall
looking on page seven point seven
seconds ago
there's about the boot camps and stuff
like that we we're not found up on their
ledger sentence of the week because
remember we've got other things we can
use with us a the channel should parked
a report like the running track out on
the in cycle track down which could
bring stuff a little bit further to the
east of the district because a lot of
those Letcher central stuff see has been
the west of the district Balian
Ashington there's not much in white
cleaning bus routes especially we might
lose a bit of what's happening with me
Freight house I've got to use why so
much
would there be anything to maybe when
you Inc more to the east of the district
before the husband is coming so if it's
really happening it's the bridge thing
point and they it's one we picked up
through the stock market testing but
with them with potential bidders so we
some documentation we produced we bases
haven't challenged we said we've got
lots of open spaces recreation space one
across the district we said how could
you actually
users better how could you encourage
football usage work with us on that and
they came up some really good ideas
these boot camps is one but lots of
other things that's coming out of that
there was a pop-up theater in chains I
found in that's great Jim and share so
lots of good examples out there yes
there's lots of opportunity to test that
as you say it's not just based
activation sciences outcome-based those
across the whole districts how it's
basically in provider services primarily
another two legged science but there's
opportunities to make that broader and
you have to to get those ideas for the
market so lots of good ideas is
overstating it thank you I think the the
ten years mentioned for contract length
is probably about right with the
opportunity for extension it's a it's a
fast more moving and an evolving area of
activity at ten ten years is a long time
with it within that so so I think we're
pitching it about right because
obviously we want to get the level of
commitment from whoever is the
successful bidder obviously in the last
contract we had the
company change hands a number of times
we learn from that and I think it's
important that we ensure that the
contract detail has the flexibility and
the protection for us should that should
that happen an equally on flexibility
because it is a fast-moving marketplace
we need to ensure that there is the
opportunity in there should Trenton's
fashions and fads move along that our
operator does have the the opportunity
and just to reiterate I believe the the
current contract model is it was
probably the most effective way forward
borders
okay right we have two recommendations
on page 7.1 items point one point one
and one for two members happy to accept
those item eight
it's the thoughtful missus producto
subcontract for monetary 2018-19
angel take this thank you this is just a
annual report to the exactly regards to
the management of the council's most
significant contracts we do have the
Marcus maps and I mean I'm here to
answer any questions with regards to
those contracts mentioned in the
appendices I wasn't quick enough to
doing so I'm happy to take back any
questions members may have with regards
to the ICT contracts I I'm not going to
go through the whole report but if we
turn if there's any questions in regards
to those contracts in me and attach
dependence or so I'm trying to scroll
down what happened to their questions
families
yeah I think I think it's just important
to reiterate that these are reports
they've give an overview of how the
contracts are performing but this isn't
the the way in which we manage our
contracts this is just a strategic
overview each one of these contracts is
measure these is monitored and
administered on a daily and weekly basis
to say the least in some cases yeah so
we pray for anyone that's looking at
this information they can be reassured
that there's much more work goes into
the managing the contracts than just
producing a strategic report once a
while questions
because requirement
poor bean returns is that we're into
contamination no it's where they are not
placed back in the correct position
slightly hard ones do following some
songs but that's just one every pond is
that static or tea
these are very much an overview so it
would give give industry headline in
case of it we do have contamination
reports as well yeah I mean simply these
reports pretty much more than all the
exercises show they have controlling the
contract which is though these is giving
you a snapshot yes there's another layer
of indicators and they found absolutely
so contamination is one of those it will
do better poison everywhere just cause
he's worth pointed out there than our
waste collection is second nationally
and most recently
not to choose a few practices really
insist an elephant
okay we have a recommendation on page
eight point one one point one that we
don't
I did
the end to the Beijing